hadamar ist luca herzlich willkommen wir
heute zu einem neuen video meine lieben
freunde denn wir machen heute dass max
was machen die reste vom habe auf
youtube das ist je gegeben hat weil ich
dich nicht sehen muss
er kann besser lügen mit mad max und
natürliche vorbereiteten mit
gegenständen und wir müssen gleich der
anderen personen zeigen dass sie diesen
gegenstand haben oder nicht haben es
geht also darum wer kann die anderen
besser an schwindel besser anlügen und
ja auch eine bestrafung so aus der
verlierer am ende
jelly beans scharfe chilis essen die wir
nicht gerade zufällig am hauptbahnhof
gesehen haben nein es war stundenlang
geplant ich versteh ich halte in meiner
hand ein buch und zwar eine kurze
geschichte der menschheit
er ist dass ich weiß dass sie das buch
gelesen hat und deswegen kann es sein
dass sie das mit genommen hast glaube
ich allerdings nicht weil du erstes nur
für 24 stunden in hamburg bist und auch
der rückfahrt ein video schneiden
wolltest du hast wahrscheinlich gesehen
dass ich das in seiner historie gesehen
habe hat er das in seiner story ich also
noch ich lese dass auch gerade deshalb
gar nicht lesen playboy
ich sag das intelligent ist und was
nicht
sagte sage ich zeige das richtige buch
ja das ist das gut zeigt dass gut das
ist das nicht das signal vom wasser lag
der schwach dass die leute beim letzten
mal als ich hier war was nicht allzu
lange her ist das war vor zwei drei
wochen
hattest du keine teebeutel sondern nur
so instant heiße zitrone zum schippen
andererseits warten sehr großes thema im
dorf ein knoten und hast du aber welchen
aktuellen der hand das ist die frage
du willst ich lüge ja/nein scheiße ich
halte in meiner hand ein mikrofon auer
war und es ist ein kamera mikrofon ist
ein kamera mikrofon
es ist eine kamera mikrofon ganz genau
was man oben auf eine dslr darauf setzt
ganz genau oder braucht eine andere
kamera okay du bist mal den knopf
du hast kein machst du hast keine gründe
haben zeigt was du da
die nächste sache die ich hier habe das
mikrofon ist eine playstation 5 what the
[ __ ] stellen wir auf den tisch die
playstation fünf tippen also auf der
oberfläche
das ist so schwer ist dass die mit oder
ohne laufwerk
das ist die mit laufwerk ok dann klappt
es mal auch das ist so verwachsen
[Musik]
ich halte in meiner hand ein
ford-sprecher bock hat sich daran
erinnern als ich das mit dem der wohnung
dann alles verspielt mit jana gestrichen
hat und ich sollte eigentlich helfen und
habe es nicht geschafft aber nicht
vorbei kann man kurzfristig wieder
abgesagt das kriegt man den deckel ab
macher deckel wieder drauf
sturzfrei bank das ist kein vorteil der
weg gehört sich nicht so an ich habe
beim nächsten produkt ein riesiges
messer liefern welcher marke ist das
schlimm
made in germany steht hier drauf wie
sieht das logo aus da sind zwillinge wie
sind die gezeichnet oder sind alle zwei
menschenleben da steckst du meinen bauch
die wahrheit kommt sehr gut und ich dich
ist auch zwilling selbstgänger
ich hatte in meiner hand und den
passenden controller playstation 59 weiß
dass ihm weggenommen haben
ja ich weiß nämlich dass den weg
genommen was bei max war zuerst im
wohnzimmer am gucken nach gegenständen
und dann hab ich die playstation fünf
daraus für räume aus meiner zeit und ich
bin das 15 controller schon nicht mehr
da liegt das heißt du hast ihn auf jeden
fall ja aber niemals in welcher runde
kommen wird okay ich habe nun hier für
dich vorbereitet
ein verhütungsmittel okay welche marke
billy boy
[Musik]
wie sind wir sind die die kanten auch
von dem vom fünf jungs mittel sind so
griffen dem fingernagel drüber ja das 1
da hast jetzt natürlich ungünstig würde
ich würde sagen lass uns dir schmecken
luca ich komme auch daran dass
videobänder die schärfe ist die kerle
einer rief er die rote die musst du auf
jeden fall essen gibt cayenne und ich
nehme es war jenes die dunkelrote dich
nehmen das ist die mitte ich nehme nicht
ganz scharfe auch
[Musik]
dh es gehe nicht darum recht negativ
aber keinen zeitdruck
der brand war auch kunde so mach keinen
scheiß hatte erst noch richtig richtig
schlafen geschliffen und ihr habt die
mittlere bei mir geht es langsam wieder
bei den bitte problem bitte probiert
wirklich ich will einfach sagen wir
dadurch dass dadurch das luft durch mein
mund geht wird das social web shop
einfach war das die ganz hell wurde
ich war das mag was sie hier
oder die hölle es wird bei mir nicht
auch es wird ein ganz klein bisschen
wenig aber es hört sich auch das war ein
kohle